you're stuck on the highway
bumper-to-bumper traffic a commute that
should have taken a few minutes has now
somehow become an hour-long endeavor and
this happens we all have one of two
thoughts one monster truck or two wish I
could just fly over this mess great news
some of Sciences greatest minds are
saying we already have them we already
have flying cars they call helicopters
well that's not quite what we meant Neal
but let's find out how the science
fiction of the flying car we all know
and love may be closer than you think to
a science reality sci-fi has long
imagined that flying cars would zip
around unencumbered by traffic in star
wars Blade Runner and the Fifth Element
flying cars just seemed right while
flying cars once seemed inevitable they
haven't quite caught on yet even though
inventors have been trying for decades
now companies like uber are developing
airborne ride-sharing but the
infrastructure and regulations don't yet
exist to support it
[Music]
but maybe flight isn't our only solution
to traffic for you men who are always
late to the office we have this built-in
Auto but we're really looking for is
found time
that's where sci-fi has been way ahead
of us with the self-driving car drive
engage may I suggest you put the car in
the Auto cruise mode for safety sake no
you may not the self-driving car may
soon be a common reality Google Tesla
Ford uber and others have been
developing self-driving cars for years
cities including Paris and Beijing are
testing self-driving cars on the road
and wham-o has released a fleet of truly
driverless taxis in Phoenix Arizona the
cars used sensors and complex algorithms
to navigate and to avoid collisions
problems have cropped up with some test
projects including crashes a pedestrian
death and even violence towards the cars
which could be typical road rage or the
quirks of interacting with AI which
sci-fi also predicted so the next time
you're feeling that road rage take a
deep breath inhale
exhale and know that the flying cars are
coming soon
[Music]
[Music]